Bolivia was promised peace what a got
was beatings bullets and a whole lot of
bedlam once boldly waving from the
balcony of the presidential palace the
self-appointed interim president
Jeannine Anna's now hides from angry
crowds who were chanting assassin killer
traitor because the woman who promised
peace
I assume the presidency with immediate
effect in line with the Constitution and
pledged to take whole measures necessary
to bring peace to the country has waged
war on journalism on politicians and on
her very own people
[Music]
the director of the state radio station
was tied to a tree and humiliated for
hours an incident that was reportedly
documented by Argentine journalist
Sebastiano Moro who was found
unconscious in his home a day later with
injuries to different parts of his body
and who died six days later various
foreign ministers described how list
containing their home addresses
telephone numbers family addresses and
other personal information are being
circulated via whatsapp Facebook and
other social media
[Music]
it has also been publicly reported that
the lifeless bodies of several people
who were killed in the massacre
disappeared allegedly after being
collected by law enforcement officers
and no further information has since
been provided on them
Anya says she's only cracking down on
the violent supporters of the previous
government but like the way it seems
it's easier to make promises of peace
when you haven't had a taste of power
yet and apparently bang has quite likes
the taste because despite promising not
to seek election may she's decided to
throw her hat into the ring after all
now Washington must be pleased it was
after all vocal in its support of the
Democratic regime change in the
latin-american country but it also
considers itself the leader of the free
world
so surely such reports of brutality
would deserve at least a slap on the
wrist no silence or as good as silence
to the killings to the beatings to the
tear gas diluted let's all be well
behaved and it's not a one-off pass
either
where was the indignation when hundreds
of human rights activists and left-wing
community leaders were killed in
Colombia or when there was a surge in
police killings in Brazilian
neighborhoods or when the Honduran
President was allegedly linked to drug
traffickers there wasn't any or it was
half-hearted at best and what do they
all have in common all the countries are
run by right-wing governments who only
have nice things to say about Donald
Trump Latin America has long been
Washington's playground from Panama to
Guatemala from Venezuela to Grenada
Washington has been keen to strong-arm
in sympathetic leaders and it seems that
once they're in human rights be damned